tragic events here on the main road
outside the north Huddersfield trust
school which unfolded around five to
three yesterday afternoon it was just
after lessons had ended the majority of
the school two children were leaving the
school this wood is an area that would
have been very very busy at that time
yesterday afternoon and police say that
they do have a number of witnesses
already identified who they are talking
to who they're Gathering evidence from
in terms of what happened here what we
know so far is that a 15 year old boy on
leaving school was attacked stabbed in
the street he was taken to Leeds General
infirmary where attempts to save him
sadly failed and he was pronounced dead
a short time after he arrived there here
at the scene only two small areas at the
moment cordoned off by police one just
here behind me where there's a bag of
what appears to be medical waste the
remnants Grim remnants of the of the
attempts by the Emergency Services one
would imagine to save this young boy's
life in another small area
just about 50 meters or so up on the
other side of the road there that's been
sealed off by police these are clearly
two key areas which forensic officers
will be examining later on today police
say that there will be further forensic
examinations here at the scene as their
investigation continues and of course an
awful lot of people to talk to in terms
of potential Witnesses potentially
dozens of witnesses many of them young
school children many of them parents one
would imagine for the police to talk to
so a lot of work to be done there
they'll also be looking for any mobile
phone footage any CCTV footage to help
them with their inquiry it's been dealt
with by the West West Yorkshire police's
homicide and major inquiry team and
their senior officer detective
superintendent Mark Bowes said our
investigation is still at a very early
stage and we will be carrying out
extensive inquiries to establish the
full circumstances surrounding this
incident that has resulted in the
absolutely senseless loss of a young
life they say that they recognize the
incidents of this nature will cause
shock and concern not only amongst 900
school children who attend the north
Huddersfield trust school but of course
of their parents and people in the local
area so they're saying that they're
going to step up patrols here kirkley's
Council are also putting people on the
ground here to reassure parents to raise
short reassure children that they are
safe as this murder investigation here
in Huddersfield continues following the
death of a 15 year old boy